die virtuelle fahrt vom tarifabschluss
den plastikbecher voll polizist der luft
verloren
die location am rechten ort besser
erschlossen twitter darüber wirklich
eine so heftig zum glück ist da eine
andere betriebe hätten unter gott wurde
schnell bis bis die rücklichter trinken
das extrem hydrazin oder sind ja
irgendwie fabios kranken fliegt bis vor
die küste libyens um flüchtlinge und
migranten in seenot zu retten
wirklich
sie schlagen kann ja immer so ein
bisschen
die karten steuer
im 2
[Musik]
was treibt diesen jungen piloten an sein
leben für flüchtlinge und migranten
einzusetzen
was rüber
der 32 jährige ostschweizer nimmt nicht
mit auf einen übungshang
gleitschirmfliegen ist sein leben
freiheit mitverantwortung das will er
als motto seinen flugschülern mitgeben
expedition im gleitschirmfliegen im
flugzeug flüge sowieso da geht's gebiert
und raffaela aufmache und penibel
vorbereitet
aber ihr jetzt grundsatz mensch eine
trophäe plan zum beispiel steht das
nächste flugzeug gang irgendwo anne und
der logopädie taiwo alles tiere plane
zeit nicht es ist anfang august
die zeitungen berichten von
rechtsnationalen aktivisten aus ganz
europa sie wollen mit einem eigenen
schiff im mittelmeer flüchtlinge und
migranten zurück nach nordafrika
schicken
fabio wundert sich was die
flüchtlingskrise so alles produzieren
kann
zehn jahren menschen auf dem schiff
sehen wir mit denen passiert wenn sie da
liegt sind und ob sie denn da bitte
einen mit bewegten sich damals und
gesichter cent je liter und delete
gesehen die sehr verwundert sind wenn
svp heimat und spuren verfolgt und ich
glaub der buch der muslime die zum
menschen zurück wissen wie man ein
dritter zug
zurück dieses wort höre ich in diesem
sommer immer wieder auch in klasse in
dieser halle landen migranten die aus
italien ohne ausweisdokumente und
deshalb rechtswidrig so die amtssprache
in die schweiz kommen
sie werden menschenwürde kontrolliert
betont patrick bands er leitet beim
grenzwachtkorps die abteilung migration
verletzt sind kriegen wo man 100
familien insbesondere sie mit acs will
mit einer entschließung zone gemacht
doch die spielecke bleibt leer
denn migranten kommen nach kars so
diesem sommer immer weniger lange müssen
wir warten bis die grenzwächter an
diesem tag überhaupt einen verdächtigen
aufgreifen dieser schwarzafrikaner hat
keine papiere gibt aber an im zug aus
mailand eingeschlafen zu sein
eigentlich wollte er schon in como
aussteigen
die grenzwächter schicken den mann nach
schneller kontrolle wieder zurück nach
italien
mir wird immer wieder gesagt auch im
flüchtlings sommer 2017 will man inkasso
nicht einfach grenzen abriegeln
ich sehe natürlich schon in auftrag
natürlich auch zur sicherheit beitragen
der schweiz 6 im ziel polizeilicher sind
wirtschaftlicher sind natürlich oder
eben migrationsbericht da haben wir
einfach und natürlich ganz wichtig
überhaupt des schadens oder auf dem
flugplatz in bielefeld treffen wir
fabius kraken wieder mit seinen freunden
sam und flo arbeitet er an einem neuen
flugzeug ein guter kauf gebraucht mit
neuem motor jeder franken zählt denn die
maschine wurde auch mit schweizer
spendengeldern finanziert fabio will
damit bis an die südgrenze europas um
vor libyen nach menschen in seenot
ausschau zu halten
der flüchtlinge und migranten kommen
weiter übers mittelmeer
[Musik]
das waren bezüglich linie u 2 bis 3
liter schluss klar natürlich gefährte
wieder zu massiven sind fröhlich
effizient durch gebirge immer größer
immer wieder da heißt wir sind immer
besser das flugzeug schon noch am limit
operieren die letzten aufkleber und die
suche und rettung in zentrale mittelmeer
kann wieder beginnen
[Musik]
auch wenn die kritik an dem freiwilligen
helfern zunehmend stärker wird fabio
muss immer wieder hören die privaten
retter würden die migranten und
flüchtlinge zur gefährlichen fahrt übers
mittelmeer verleiten noch mehr tote
provozieren
spender die na'vis enzian sind merkt
natürlich massiv dass das dir zu können
und das stimmig nicht sehr offen ist für
die arbeit wurde der gleiche tut und da
mitstreiter sehen meint die organisation
nur seien bewusst sieht dass das ja dass
man alles schlecht sind
für viele geht und die tief stehen das
bedeutet und
die audis lefty speziell das menschlich
hat es mir nicht eine grüne bietet und
der schau ganz groß punkt ist das medium
wieder betont dass mehrere unpolitisch
sind es gar nicht mit politischen
diskussion riesgo zum zweiten treffer
von angel aber und dass die situation am
mittelmeer herrschenden tag war ich
vielleicht auch weil in ihre heimat
alles so heil und geordnet scheint im
appenzellerland in bühler haben fabio
und sam ihre gleitschirmflieger schule
hier planen sie auch die humanitären
einsätze fabio ist da ganz genau
er weiß sehr viele augen schauen
momentan aufs mittelmeer
die libysche küstenwache hat den
privaten rettungsschiffe sogar verboten
zu nah an ihrer küste zu operieren
auch deshalb wird fabio jeden flug
einsatz genau ankündigen kommuniziert
und haben ja da ist so komplett ist
absehbar ist für alle beteiligten der
region also der theorie denn direkte
kontakte und e mail adresse wo die
zuständige stelle für die russin stand
ihr lernen wichtig für die richtig
schief dass sie wissen wir sind in der
luft
und wenn sie das problem hängt oder
bisher hat das ist dann könnte reise und
da steht alles drin wir sie ist rente
reicht eine welle frequenzen das jahr
wieder sehr in dieser für als instrument
zur zeige wenn sie unterstütze geboren
inkasso kontrollieren die grenzwächter
inzwischen die züge die aus italien
kommen
zu viert führen sie einen kräftigen mann
ab patrick benz bleibt ruhig und
konzentriert
alltag an der schweizer südgrenze die
blockierte türk wie sie die kollegen oft
und er sie blockiert hat bis hintergrund
dieser beruf braucht hat sich verstecken
der mann wird identifiziert seine
fingerabdrücke werden mit der datei des
grenzwachkorps 's abgeglichen
dann geht es zum gespräch
warum ist er in die schweiz gekommen
hier wird entschieden ob der
aufgegriffene an die italiener rück oder
an staatssekretariat für migration
weiter überwiesen wird
schnell stellt sich heraus der mann ist
kein unbekannter
[Musik]
fünfmal und über verschiedene namen
braucht geburtsdatum gleich zwei mal den
versuch das asylgesuch gestellt sowie
sheen hat das noch zurückzogen und ist
noch wieder kreist unter natur wieder
versucht p 2s und jetzt fisch moritz mit
ihrer begründung erklärte galliani
kollege und dann wird darüber gehen
für ihn heißt es zurück der ansturm an
die schweizer grenze bleibt heute aus
die letzten stunden am flugplatz
birrfeld fabio hat nur noch den tüv
termin dann sind alle papiere für das
flugzeug bereit
was noch fehlt ist die verabschiedung
von den spendern und helfern die dieses
hilfsprojekt überhaupt erst möglich
gemacht haben
[Musik]
im hangar des flieger museums von
altenrhein wird das neue flugzeug
vorgestellt
ich spüre die vorfreude bei fabio seinen
freunden verwandten und förderern
auch wenn vater und mutter schon ihre
sorgen haben
mit der lebenswirklichkeit all das was
können wir daraus machen
die informationslage gut beurteilen und
ist eine variation machen als
draufgänger tritt fabio auch heute nicht
auf ruhig und überlegt schildert er sein
hilfsprojekt allererste stückchen
schöner moment aber umgehend idee
funktioniert das funktionieren könnte
nicht schöner hätte und dass man das
allerwichtigste für wieso man abstand so
die ganze gesagt ja was da läuft und
dass der menschen sind und kind sind und
familie sind da spielt wo mir aus der
luft zehn tagen weiter regelmäßig das
ist ein sehr schwieriges tagsüber hagen
rether oder weg sich wo man wirklich
aber auch vielen keine medikamente
setzte sich verwundert liegt direkt zwei
bretter das wirklich direkt lied du in
zehn ob sie sind wo ohne luftaufklärung
chance fightet
und wir sind bitter koordination debtx
koordination in der luft ungefähr wie
bei 18.000 personen
pixie ja darum vielen dank
nicht mit ein paar prioritär wenig
engagement sind die versionen mit ihm
heraus wenn er mir verzählt den weiß ich
dass das sinn traum ist sich nicht wenn
illusionslose oder wie somit realistisch
ist sondern es ist so am großen ganzen
zu bringen für babies kurz druck spüren
der erwerb sei sie nie sicher liegen
sich nicht nur sondern sich die fliegen
[Musik]
es wird ernst mit einem befreundeten
fluglotsen aus deutschland fliegt fabio
vorbei an rigi und pilatus richtung
süden
das wetter für die alpenüberquerung
passt ein letzter blick auf den gotthard
und fabio denkt schon ans mittelmeer
sein einsatzgebiet
[Musik]
das heißt es
bei diesem blick kommen mir
notsituationen gar nicht in den sinn
denn fabio legt musik auf
[Musik]
vorbei an sizilien in südliche
mittelmeer zu schön der blick auf gozo
[Musik]
der anflug über malta
nach sechs stunden flug und einem
tankstopp touchdown im einsatzgebiet
[Musik]
das hotel bravo kilo mic mic die
maschine mit ihrer kennung aus der
schweiz rollt in die neue wahlheimat
nach einem langen flug endlich am boden
endlich beine ausstrecken
die ruhe währt nur kurz auf fabio warten
formulare denn das flugzeug muss betankt
sei für den ersten wirklichen einsatz
tag
den fliegt der schweizer mit maria von
der deutschen rettungsorganisation cbot
ein langer tag geht auch inkasso zu ende
patrick benz macht eine letzte
kontrollfahrt auch oberhalb des bahnhofs
ist mit migranten zu rechnen
auf alten schmuggler pfaden sind
natürlich eine schlechte kopie rico
jetzt wieder aktiv worden sind wird
nachfrage einfach nach einer nach wie
vor häufig es ist natürlich auch will
mir sind sprechens control dispositiv
hans wo die leute nicht das kann immer
bei mir natürlich schwerpunkt controller
machen das eigentlich aufgabe sieht aus
wie auf alternative weg auf kliniken zu
begangen oder eben ganz vereinzelt im
moment noch zwischen der grünen grenze
die grenzwächter müssen jedem hinweis
nachgehen
das ist oft mühsam lädt aber auch ein in
der ruhe der nacht über die hektik des
tages nachzudenken
sehr schön ist auch und dann geht es
doch im moment als grenzwache befehligte
nur pro mannschaft und klima man kann
darüber studieren und gleich überzeugt
ich versichere norbert und saubermacher
leisten migranten oder flüchtlinge sind
in dieser nacht keine mehr gekommen
tja so bleibt in diesem sommer ruhig
auffallend ruhig
in malta ist fabio schon wieder auf den
beinen
zum ersten mal wird er heute mit seinem
neuen flugzeug als luft aufklärer
private rettungsorganisationen
unterstützen
jene angeles die im mittelmeer nach
migranten und flüchtlingen ausschau
halten
maria wird den kontakt zu den
rettungshilfen halten
auf uns wartet ein großes suchgebiet
das heißt die libysche küste wo die
lampen live dieses leblos geborgen
es bietet nicht nur sieben nationale
krise
sind zu tragen zu kalt - und es immer
wieder gerüchte zurück
was natürlich
so bot das trio mit dieser punkt nicht
gut los
30 jahren belegten dass durch gewertet
zu hause mit höchsten weg geht das wird
sehr schwierig macht teilwiese student
vordere position zu einer position
nach nur einer flugstunde hat die
libysche küste
fabio meldet sich bei der libyschen
fluggesellschaft
weit in internationalen gewässern stoßen
wir auf das erste private rettungsschiff
östlich von tripoli dann
flüchtlingsboote ein weißes schlauchboot
voller roter punkte menschen mit
schwimmwesten
maria dokumentiert und meldet die
position des schlauchbootes an die
rettungsschiffe
[Gelächter]
er wohnt noch immer gut was die ihren
respektiven
ein privates rettungsschiff nimmt kurs
auf
am ende des tages werden 228 flüchtlinge
und migranten auf offener see gerettet
für fabio hat sich der erste einsatz tag
mit dem neuen flugzeug gelohnt
zurück in malta heißt es stress abbauen
extrem ruhig ruhig die luft aus spanien
ohne wolle viel übrig fabio hat ein
anliegen das lebt er grenzenlos